Finlandia es un país famoso por tener la
mayor concentración de bandas de heavy metal
per cápita del mundo.
No.
Esto no me lo he inventado.
Alguien en internet se dedicó a hacer un
estudio con un mapa incluido.
Pero vamos a centrarnos en el tema de hoy.
Como os podéis imaginar, hoy no vamos a hablar
de Finlandia por el metal.
Estas semanas, tanto Suecia como Finlandia
están en todos los medios de comunicación
por esta razón.
(Suecia y Finlandia solicitan, formalmente
y de la mano, su entrada en la OTAN)
Como os podéis imaginar, esto es todo un
golpe para Rusia.
Sobre todo en el caso de Finlandia.
De hecho, si no os importa, en este vídeo
vamos a poner más énfasis en Finlandia.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué?
¿Qué importancia tienen Suecia y Finlandia
para la OTAN?
A fin de cuentas, hablamos de dos países
con poca población.
Suecia tiene poco más de 10 millones de habitantes
y Finlandia poco más de 5 millones y medio
¿Por qué es semejante desgracia para Rusia
que entren en la OTAN?
¿Qué problemas pueden encontrarse estos
dos países por el camino?
¿De verdad pueden llegar a entrar en la OTAN?
¿Y qué puede hacer Rusia para evitarlo?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
Pero antes de todo…..
Una pregunta: ¿Alguna vez has pensado cuánta
deuda hay en todo el mundo?
Ojo, que no es ninguna tontería.
Según el Fondo Monetario Internacional (FMI)
y el Instituto de Finanzas Internacionales,
el mundo nunca ha estado tan endeudado.
Y lo que resulta aún más llamativo: Esta
vorágine de préstamos, créditos y bonos
de todo tipo no para de crecer.
Ahora bien, ¿quiénes son los responsables
de esta situación?
¿Cuánta deuda hay?
¿Qué puede suponer para la economía mundial?
¿Estamos al borde de sufrir una enorme crisis
de deuda mundial?
Pues si queréis conocer la respuesta a todas
estas preguntas no os perdais el último vídeo
de Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
LA
HISTORIA SE REPITE)
Podríamos decir que Ucrania es un deja vu
de Finlandia.
Estos dos países tienen tantos puntos en
común que parece que son la misma historia
con distintos personajes.
Al igual que Ucrania, Finlandia también formó
parte del Imperio Ruso.
En el año 1917, lograron la independencia.
Sin embargo, en el año 1939, Stalin decidió
invadirles.
Y diréis ¿Por qué?
¿Qué razones tenían los rusos para invadir
a los pobres finlandeses?
¿Cuál era la narrativa del Kremlin para
justificar la guerra contra Finlandia?
Pues atentos a este poster de propaganda soviética.
¡Exacto!
Es justo lo que parece: un nazi que está
llevando un perrito con una correa.
El perrito es una alegoría de Finlandia.
De hecho, no sé si podéis ver bien el texto,
pero dice “ladra el perro del fascista”
¡Habéis oído bien!
Según Stalin, Rusia tenía que conquistar
Finlandia para…
¡Desnazificarla!
Así es como estalló la llamada guerra de
invierno.
Una guerra que Rusia esperaba ganar en pocas
semanas.
La Unión Soviética superaba a Finlandia
en todos los frentes: tenían más soldados,
mejores armas y más dinero.
Sin embargo, los finlandeses opusieron resistencia.
Conocían mucho mejor el terreno y sabían
resistir el frío mucho mejor que nadie.
Desde entonces, Finlandia todavía tiene regimientos
enteros de soldados esquiadores.
(En esta guerra es donde se forjaron leyendas
como SIMO HAYHA, más conocido como “La
muerte blanca”.
Se trata del francotirador más mortífero
de la historia.
505 muertes confirmadas.
Tras 100 días de guerra en las condiciones
más extremas que os podáis imaginar, Rusia
se retiró.)
Seguramente muchos ya conozcáis esta historia.
Lo que no se suele contar es que Finlandia
no ganó la guerra.
Al menos no fue una victoria rotunda.
Aparte del coste humano y todos los destrozos
de la guerra, Finlandia tuvo que pagar 300
millones de dólares a Rusia como reparación.
Para que os hagáis una idea, eso serían
como 5.780 millones de dólares de hoy en
día.
Además, Rusia se quedó con un par de regiones
del norte de Finlandia y con buena parte de
Karelia.
Y la pregunta que muchos os estaréis haciendo
¿Mereció la pena?
¿Hizo bien Finlandia en plantar cara a Rusia?
¿O tal vez habría sido mejor ahorrarse la
guerra?
La respuesta no podía ser más rotunda: SÍ.
Los datos hablan por sí solos.
A día de hoy, los finlandeses disfrutan de
un PIB per capita de 49.000 dólares.
La República de Karelia no llega a 7170 dólares
¿Esperanza de vida?
En Finlandia es de 81 años.
En Rusia es de 73 ¿Desigualdad?
Finlandia es uno de los países más igualitarios
del mundo, con un coeficiente de Gini de 27,7.
Rusia, por el contrario, es muchísimo más
desigual, con un coeficiente de Gini de 35,3.
En otras palabras: da igual el indicador que
miremos: Finlandia está entre las mejores
posiciones y Rusia entre las peores.
Probablemente, los ponres karelienses que
estén en la frontera con Finlandia se estén
preguntando todos los días por qué sus antepasados
no consiguieron que la frontera se moviera
un poco más hacia el Este.
De hecho, la República de Karelia es una
de las regiones con menos apoyo al partido
de Putin.
Aunque eso poco importa en la democracia rusa.
Dicho de otra manera: hay pocos ejemplos donde
una frontera marca una diferencia tan grande
en la vida de los ciudadanos.
Pero ahora la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo
todos es…
¿Por qué es tan importante que Finlandia
(y Suecia) se unan a la OTAN?
¿Qué aportan a la alianza?
¿Es simplemente un movimiento simbólico
o hay algo más?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
2(¿NO QUERÍAS OTAN?
¡PUES TOMA OTAN!)
Finlandia y Suecia son dos de los países
más difíciles de invadir del mundo.
Son dos ejemplos de lo que podríamos llamar
“seguridad total”.
Es decir, que toda la sociedad está preparada
para una invasión: desde militares hasta
civiles.
(Para que os hagáis una idea, Suecia tiene
más de 65.000 refugios para caso de guerra.
De hecho, en algunas regiones suecas es obligatorio
que todas las casas tengan su propio bunker.
Sólo en HELSINKI, la capital de Finlandia,
hay más de 5.500 búnkeres.
Además, tanto Finlandia como Suecia tienen
ejércitos bien armados y perfectamente adaptados
a las exigencias de la OTAN.)
Pero hay algo mucho más importante que todo
eso.
La gran aportación de Finlandia y Suecia
a la OTAN es…
¡La geografía!
Atentos a este mapa.
Aquí podéis ver el mar Báltico.
Finlandia y Estonia controlan toda la salida
de Rusia al Báltico desde San Petersburgo.
Estonia ya está en la OTAN.
Si Finlandia entra, la OTAN podría cerrar
el tráfico de los barcos rusos que salen
de San Petersburgo.
Y diréis ¡Vale!
Rusia todavía tiene una salida al Báltico
¡Kaliningrado!
¡Pero esperad un momento!
Porque justo, en frente de Kaliningrado está
Suecia ¡Que también está a punto de entrar
en la OTAN!
(Suecia también tiene esta isla que veis
aquí: la isla de Gotland.
Hasta hace meses, esta isla estaba desmilitarizada.
Pero Suecia ya ha enviado tropas.
Y, desde ahí, puede controlar toda esta zona
del Báltico ¿Conclusión?
Rusia quería evitar tener a la OTAN en su
frontera.
Ahora va a estar rodeada de la OTAN en el
único punto por donde pueden salir al Atlántico.
Si quieren fletar un submarino con cabezas
nucleares, por ejemplo, es casi imposible
que no lo detecte un radar.
Pensad que todos los ejércitos de la OTAN
comparten información.
)
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¿De verdad
es tan importante el Mar Báltico para Rusia?
Técnicamente, también tienen acceso al mar
negro.
El mar negro también es un mar de aguas calientes
¿El problema?
Fijaos en este otro mapa.
Si os fijáis, veréis que la única salida
del Mar Negro hacia el mar Mediterráneo es…
¡El estrecho del Bósforo, que está en Turquía!
Y sí, Turquía también está en la OTAN.
Dicho de otra manera: Rusia podría estar
a punto de perder el control de toydas sus
salidas al mar.
Al menos en la parte Occidental.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Fijaos en este otro mapa.
Este saliente que veis en la parte rusa es
la península de Kola.
Se estima que esta es la zona con más silos
nucleares del mundo.
Aquí es donde Rusia tendría casi todas sus
cabezas nucleares y bases de aviación.
Según CaspianReport, todas estas bases militares
están conectadas por una única línea de
ferrocarril ¡Habéis oído bien!
Estamos diciendo que la mayor parte del arsenal
nuclear ruso estaría conectado por una única
línea de tren.
Bastaría con un ataque bien orquestado y
todas las líneas de logística que alimentan
ese arsenal nuclear colapsarían.
Hasta ahora, nada de esto era un problema
para Rusia.
Los únicos que podrían sabotear esa línea
de ferrocarril serían los finlandeses.
Pero Finlandia no estaba en la OTAN y era
neutral.
Todo esto está a punto de cambiar.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar lo que esto
supone para Rusia.
Paréntesis: esto no significa que Rusia perdería
todas sus bombas nucleares.
Pero está claro que sería más difícil
para Rusia poder echar mano de todo su arsenal
nuclear.
Dicho de otra manera: Finlandia en la OTAN
es algo que Rusia no se puede permitir.
La pregunta es ¿Qué pueden hacer para evitarlo?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
3(DEMASIADO TARDE PARA ACTUAR)
¿Cuántas veces habéis oído hablar de la
“expansión de la OTAN”?
Según la propaganda rusa, la OTAN es como
una mancha de aceite que va tomando nuevos
países.
Como estamos viendo en este caso, no es la
OTAN quien se expande.
Son los países que se sienten amenazados
por Rusia los que buscan protección.
Ahora bien, entrar en la OTAN no es un proceso
automático.
Desde que un país solicita su entrada hasta
que finalmente entra hay un periodo donde
es especialmente débil.
Pensadlo bien: una vez que Suecia y Finlandia
entren en la OTAN, Rusia no podría atacarles.
Sería un ataque contra la OTAN en su conjunto.
Sin embargo, hasta que eso ocurra, Rusia podría
lanzar pequeños ataques sin que la OTAN estuviera
obligada a responder.
Eso explica amenazas como esta.
Rusia amenaza con represalias técnicas y
militares por la entrada de Finlandia en la
OTAN)
Y diréis ¿Pero qué puede hacer Rusia?
En principio, podrían lanzar misiles de crucero
a ciertos sitios estratégicos en Finlandia.
Podrían destruir centrales eléctricas, torres
de comunicaciones y colapsar toda la economía.
Sin el apoyo de la OTAN, Finlandia no podría
responder ¿O tal vez sí?
Atentos.
Reino Unido Lanza un nuevo acuerdo de seguridad
con Suecia y Finlandia)
¡Habéis oído bien!
Boris Johnson ha sido más rápido que la
propia OTAN.
Antes de que el resto de países miembros
decidan si aceptan a Finlandia y Suecia, Reino
Unido ya ha prometido cooperación militar.
Eso significa que, si Moscú ataca, Londres
responde.
Y recordad que Reino Unido sí tiene armas
nucleares ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Después del movimiento de Reino Unido, otros
países han seguido la estela.
Después llegó Polonia y después, Estados
Unidos ¿Conclusión?
La ventana de oportunidad para Rusia ya se
ha cerrado.
Aunque Finlandia y Suecia no estén en la
OTAN todavía, ya tienen el apoyo de 2 potencias
nucleares ¿Pueden atacar con medidas económicas?
¡Por supuesto!
El Kremlin ya ha anunciado que corta todo
el suministro de gas a Finlandia.
Y eso es un problema.
Pero, desde el punto de vista militar, cada
vez tienen menos opciones.
Y eso explica que días después de amenazar
con tantas represalias, el discurso de Moscú
haya cambiado radicalmente.
Atentos.
(El ministro de Asuntos Exteriores de Rusia,
Sergei Lavrov, dice que la entrada de Suecia
y Finlandia en la OTAN no marca una gran diferencia)
¡Habéis oído bien!
No marca una gran diferencia.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando…
entonces, si Rusia no puede hacer nada…
es cuestión de tiempo que Finlandia entre
en la OTAN ¿Verdad?
¿Es posible que algo salga mal?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
4(TIEMPO DE NEGOCIACIONES)
En principio, la OTAN tiene una política
de puertas abiertas.
Es decir, que Finlandia y Suecia podrían
entrar sin problemas ¿El problema?
El problema es que todos los países miembros
tienen que aceptarlo.
Sin excepción.
Y diréis ¿Qué países querrían vetar la
entrada de Suecia y Finlandia en la OTAN?
Pues principalmente dos: Hungría y Turquía.
Especialmente Turquía.
Atentos.
La Turquía de Erdogan relaciona la entrada
de la Suecia y Finlandia en la OTAN con que
devuelvan a los “terroristas”.)
Los que estáis suscritos a nuestro boletín
semanal ya lo conocéis: Turquía lleva años
luchando contra la minoría kurda.
Turquía tiene a varias organizaciones kurdas
en su lista de grupos terroristas.
Sin embargo, tanto Suecia como Finlandia han
dado asilo político a miembros de estas organizaciones.
Concretamente, estos dos países se han negado
a extraditar a 33 individuos.
Según Turquía, esto implica colaborar con
terroristas.
Y no están dispuestos a aceptar la entrada
de Suecia y Finlandia hasta que no colaboran
en su lucha contra los kurdos ¡Pero no sólo
hablamos de kurdos!
Según Erdogan, también se incluye en la
lista de grupos terroristas a los seguidores
de Fetullah Gullen.
Si recordáis, Fetullah Gullen es uno de los
enemigos políticos de Erdogan y uno de los
principales instigadores del golpe de estado
del año 2016.
La pregunta es…
¿De verdad esta es la única razón?
Pues es muy probable que no.
Os lo hemos contado varias veces en VisualPolitik:
Turquía es el enfant terrible de la OTAN.
Y eso significa que Estados Unidos les ha
vetado de la compra de muchas armas.
Por ejemplo, Turquía no puede comprar F-35s.
Sin embargo, ahora pueden utilizar su poder
de veto para renegociar.
Y, por el momento, está dando resultados.
Atentos.
Turquía confirma que Reino Unido ha levantado
el embargo en las exportaciones de material
de defensa)
Y diréis ¡Pues ya está!
La OTAN volverá a vender armas a Turquía
como si no hubiera pasado nada.
A cambio, Turquía aceptará a Suecia y Finlandia…
¡Asunto resuelto!
¿Verdad?
¡Pues no es tan sencillo!
De nuevo, Turquía es el niño problemático
de la OTAN ¿Por qué?
Pues, entre otras muchas cosas, por su eterna
animadversión por otro miembro de la OTAN:
Grecia.
Es muy probable que Grecia no esté muy contenta
si su principal antagonista vuelve a tener
acceso al arsenal militar de última generación
de Estados Unidos.
Y todavía está en el aire otra pregunta
¿Hasta qué punto Hungría puede vetar esta
nueva expansión de la OTAN?
¿De verdad va a ser posible solucionar todas
estas diferencias?
Una cosa está clara: salvo Turquía y Hungría,
parece que todos los demás miembros están
más que decididos a aceptar nuevos miembros.
La pregunta es ¿Cómo van a conseguir convencer
a Hungría y Turquía?
¿De verdad Suecia y Finlandia van a terminar
entrando en la OTAN?
¿Existe alguna forma de que Rusia lo consiga
evitar?
¿Veremos una campaña de propaganda masiva
para intentar convencer a los europeos de
que Finlandia y Suecia son países dominados
por los nazis?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Recordad también que podéis apoyarnos en
Patreon y accederéis a nuestra newsletter,
contenido exclusivo y… ¡merchandising!
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.